good day i'm melinda kligman the public
impact director at the innovative
genomics institute which is a
collaboration between the university of
california berkeley and the university
of california san francisco founded in
2014 by jennifer doudna with the goal of
using genome engineering to solve some
of humanity's greatest problems
as part of her strategy we focus on
crispr applications for human health and
continuing to develop innovative new
genomics tools
relevant to our discussion today a
significant portion of our work is also
focused on climate change and it is a
core part of our mission to advance
public understanding of the benefits of
genome engineering
and to ensure that any benefits of the
technology are advanced in an equitable
and ethical way
so we've already heard from researchers
who use genome editing in their labs and
who have painted a picture of the
current approaches to use genome editing
to address climate change
but as a breeder you may ask what
happens after one develops a
genome-edited trait in their lab and
tested in the greenhouse
what would be the next steps
and so the answer to this is that the
time and cost does depend partially on
where you are located
so at a very simplified level
researchers will identify and develop
new improved approaches and tools that
they can
use to identify new traits and these
traits are sources of productivity
stress tolerance
or helps with climate adaptation
so these traits are then introduced into
the breeding pipeline where they are
integrated into high performing
varieties
and then here on phase four things can
really change depending on whether the
product is categorized
as a transgenic or a gm product or gmos
in a specific country
the researcher may have requirements
around field testing the traits
if the product is deemed to be a gm
product they may need to put together a
significant regulatory package of data
that includes a battery of tests for
product safety and then they will need
to take that to the country's
biotechnology regulator for review and
that review can sometimes take years
if it is deemed that the product is not
regulated or similar to a conventionally
bred product
which is the case for some genome edited
products
then the product would not necessarily
need to go through that process
um and i'll talk a little bit more about
that later
um but from there any product
conventionally read or gm
would need to be scaled up and
distributed via the appropriate pathways
for whatever particular system you're in
so where exactly is that line drawn
between what's considered to be a
genetically modified
or gm product or living modified
organism
um or a genome edited product
so globally regulators have taken a very
practical approach that is informed by
the 35 years experience that they have
with transgenic more gmo plants
most regulators globally did not want to
have to issue new laws
although some are doing so for example
in india
new laws can be really difficult and
take time to move forward so instead
they've opted to interpret their
existing walls to determine whether
genome-edited products fell within the
existing definitions of a gmo
and then determine from there whether
those products could be excluded from
their oversight and treated as a
conventional byproduct
and most of the language and existing
laws was drafted
in the late 80s or early 90s
it makes a reference to recombinant dna
technology
and a novel combination of genes
as a trigger for regulation
so with some types of genome edits like
single point mutations
um deletions and introduction of dna
sequences from sexually compatible
relatives
a lot of regulators have deemed that
this is not a novel combination of
genetic material
and so some countries had said that
these products would not be regulated by
the rules meant to provide oversight for
biotechnology
although all food is still subject to
rules around food safety
which is similar to what conventionally
bred products also have to go through
so there's also a practical another
practical reason why regulators have
chosen this approach
um if something could have occurred
naturally or by conventional breeding
it's really impossible to tell which
products are genome edited in order to
require or ask for more data
so regulators are also thinking about
enforcement and also just a general
point of regulations which is for safety
and if you can't tell the difference
then there's really no point in
so as you can see from this map most of
the countries in the americas have taken
this approach
and several countries in asia and africa
are considering similar approaches
japan has taken a bit more of a
conservative approach where they're
saying if dna if any dna is introduced
so even if it's from a sexually
compatible relative for instance they're
considering that to be regulated
the one outlier
was the eu
where a court case determined that
genome-edited products fell into their
definition as a gmo as was written in
law
but earlier this year they have said
that the law as written is not fit for
purpose
and they're likely going to go about
updating that language
hopefully with more flexible language to
allow them to better adapt to new
technologies in the future
some countries haven't said anything yet
and a lot of these countries are
treating genome-edited products
as they are gm until they can establish
their laws
so just to recap
if you are considered to have a
transgenic product you may require
multi-location field trials and regulate
and regulate it as a gmo
on the need to submit a significant
regulatory package
but if the product falls into a category
of an excluded genome-edited product
it may just be treated as conventionally
spread and can move forward in the
pipeline potentially saving the
developer a lot of time and a lot of
money
and in some cases it could mean the
product getting out at all there are
examples where due to public perception
and regulatory and political roadblocks
some products have just never been put
on the market
and i think the most famous example is
the transgenic humanitarian golden rice
to prevent childhood blindness
so how big is this difference in cost
and time so
um
industry experts
uh
estimate that it can take about 14 13 to
14 years to commercialize a gm product
with about five years of that time taken
up with collecting the data for the
regulatory dossier and waiting for
regulatory approvals
um
and they estimate a much reduced cost
and time for genome edited products with
about five years and 10 million dollars
so particularly if we look at a crop
like wheat
you know for which there's currently no
jam varieties on the market
you know genetic diversity for disease
resistance has been lost over time
through bottlenecks from
polyploidization and domestication so
genome editing could play a role here
perhaps in bringing in disease
resistance resistance genes from wild
relatives
or developing varieties that can adapt
to
a range of climatic conditions
and since wheat does not generate a lot
of farm revenue compared to maize
it has not really been a target for
genetic modification
since presumably industry can't really
recover the cost associated with the
research investment
but if we have
a reduced cost and shorter times then
perhaps we might see some more public
researchers or small companies looking
into different solutions
and you know is this what we're seeing
in practice
and the short answer is yes so
in 2015 argentinian regulators pioneered
the model for how to regulate new
breeding techniques
they do require a case-by-case approach
so developers need to come in to
regulators to have their products
reviewed and products that don't have a
novel combination of genetic material is
released via existing health and safety
rules for conventionally bred products
so that was now six years ago so we have
some some early data
in 2020 the key regulators in that
country published a paper summarizing
what they found and this provides an
early example of the impact of
regulations on innovations
so right now on the screen this is the
type of developers that have submitted
applications for transgenic gmo products
the first approval was made in argentina
in 1996 of a herbicide resistant soybean
and you can see from this graph that
most emissions 90 of them were made by
foreign multinational companies
so if we compare this to genome-edited
applications by developers um we see a
wider range of distribution of who have
submitted applications
um we actually have more developers with
13 different institutions for genome
edited products
compared to just 10 institutions for the
gm product developers
and this is a comparison of 23 years of
products submitted for the gmos versus
just a three year period
evaluated for the genome edited products
and down below on the second panel um we
have the types of products that have
been submitted and if you look at the
difference between gm o's and or gm
products and genome edited products
there's a much wider variety of
genome-edited products submitted and
here again fewer applications
fewer total overall number of
applications and a shorter time frame
but still a much wider variety in just
those three years
and so what this highlights to me is
what people have been saying for a long
time but not with a lot of concrete
evidence
it shows that the cost of regulation can
really shrink the number of players that
are able to operate
and even for large multinational
companies they are limited to what they
develop because they can only focus on
crops that can be the most profitable
since the regulatory burden is very high
and so overly onerous regulations can
actually end up having the opposite
effect
i think a lot of calls by civil society
organizations for increased regulations
on gm products um is aimed explicitly at
limiting the activity of large
multinational companies but the outcome
is that it's too expensive or difficult
for all but the largest and most
well-funded players working on a tiny
fraction of trades and crops
and so that leads to more consolidation
at least monocultures
and by lowering the regulatory barrier
you can see a widening field of
companies and local and public research
institutions
because you have a wider range of
institutions you're going to have a wide
range of products people have different
interests
and some of these
new products might be consumer facing
related to sustainability or climate
change
instead of solely focused on increasing
yields and profitability
so this is exciting to me i think
it portends a really interesting future
as the landscape continues to evolve
and i personally think one of the
potentially biggest beneficiaries could
be smallholder farmers
another thing that came out of the
argentinian study is that there's a big
increase in the quantity of applications
over time for genome edited products
it's rising very quickly
and so if we put this all together you
know the products are easier and faster
to develop
potentially cheaper this makes just
means they're more accessible
and this is all
particularly useful in lmic's
so that the cgiar which
is a top class research center located
in lmic's i think they operate in over
100 countries globally
have averaged um have said that the
average age of a variety in the farmer
fields in the countries in which they
operate is 12 to 25 years
compared to three to five years in the
u.s
for corn soybean and for barley in
western europe
so using these old varieties
really leaves farmers at risk for
evolving pests and diseases and a
changing climate
and it deprives them of the progress of
breeding
and so i think what is powerful about
genome editing is that it could lead to
more responsive breeding because of the
shorter turnover times
and so breeders can provide a steady
stream of new varieties to respond to
changing climatic
conditions
but to make this a reality for lmics
it's going to be really important for us
to learn from the past and to empower
local breeders to develop and use
technology themselves
so you know scientists in the cg system
local national agricultural research
institutes are really important because
they understand the local context and
the
know what the local farmers consumers
and environmental priorities are
and one of the big criticisms of gm
technology is that it was western
developed
and so i think here it's important
that this not solely be a western
technology
but the homegrown
so the last thing i want to talk about
is public perception um we can't really
ignore it i think it's a big part of why
gm products have not been widely adopted
in lmic's and a part of the negative
feedback loop of why there are high
regulatory requirements and consumer
rejection
and so this is a big concern that we as
scientists need to appreciate and try to
address where possible before products
hit the market
so to give you an example of some data
yang and hobbs in 2020 published study
on the perception of genetically
modified and genome-edited foods
they asked people to rate from one to
six
whether they thought foods produced with
a particular breeding technique that's
natural ethical and safe to eat
for this graph on the y-axis we have the
rating scale with one being not at all
safe
natural or ethical and six being
completely
and the colors are darkest blue for
crossbred plants which received
the highest ratings across the board
light blue from mutagenesis which i
think it's funny because it's considered
a conventional breeding technique but
it's rated quite lowly
the horizontal hashtags are gm or
transgenics and the
hashtags of an angle are genome edits
which received somewhat intermediary
scores here
and when we look at other similar
studies published to date we see a
similar distribution
um so these studies have measured
people's attitudes perceptions or
willingness to buy products and at what
cost
and i've grossly oversimplified the
studies here so i can compare them
roughly
um but you can see conventional breeding
techniques generally receive a highest
positive mark with the two plus signs
genome-edited products are usually
somewhere in the middle in regards to
perception
or there's mixed perception among
different countries surveyed
and then the two negative signs indicate
that consumers had a negative
association with the breeding technique
or at least
the most negative compared to the other
options with which they were presented
and so i think overall it shows that
consumers are still a little bit more
open to genome-edited products
and then with the question around
mutagenesis it really shows you how
framing and kind of preconceptions about
uh
you know a particular word can have an
effect on how individuals
um think about
think about a product
this second paper that looked at them at
um
it's from australia
and they showed that when consumers
found out that they were already eating
products of mutagenesis and it was
considered a conventional breeding
technique that they that their
perception of it improved
so what can you as a scientist do about
all of this um so in the u.s
you know the public has a fairly high
perception of scientists
and this has been relatively stable
since the 1970s
and then in addition a lot of people are
getting their news from social media for
better or worse
so you as a scientist have a direct
platform to provide information about
your work
to your friends and family who will
likely trust your opinion and i know i
frequently i'm nervous about doing this
but then i'm reminded by you know
instagram influencer dietitians in my
social circle who have no medical or
scientific training
really giving out advice to their
followers about why you know kale is bad
for you and why you should never eat it
um and i realized okay maybe i do know a
little bit more about this and so you
shouldn't be self-conscious about
engaging because you likely do have some
training
i know this is not the space if social
media is not the space in which you want
to engage because it can sometimes be a
little hostile you can still make a
difference through structured outreach
programs um at your university or local
science centers or museums
i like to say if you're going to use the
tools in the lab then you should be
invested in conveying about its safety
and usefulness
and most importantly
why the use of technologies can be
aligned to societal values
and how these new tools can really help
us reach our goals around sustainability
and climate change
so thank you so much for your time and
attention